Olá, será que você deve ou não
suplementar vitamina C ou isso é só
jogar dinheiro fora? Afinal, essa é a
vitamina mais popular que existe, mas
talvez você esteja usando de forma
errada. Outra dúvida comum é sobre qual
é a dose correta, se existe o mínimo,
existe um máximo, se devemos suplementar
de tempos em tempos ou sem parar de
forma prolongada. São muitas dúvidas que
eu recebo todos os dias. Então é isso
que eu vou responder nesse vídeo. A
vitamina C é solúvel em água, o que
significa que apenas uma certa
quantidade é usada pelo corpo e o
excesso é escretado, portanto não pode
ser armazenada, o que torna necessário
restaurar continuamente os níveis de
vitamina C para garantir uma ingestão
adequada. Primeiro, eu quero que você
entenda que nada é melhor do que obter a
vitamina C através de uma alimentação
saudável, balanceada, consumindo
alimentos ricos em vitamina C no seu dia
a dia. Sabe por quê? Assim como a
vitamina C é famosa por ajudar a
entralizar radicais livres, ela própria
pode ser afetada por esses radicais e se
transformar em um radical livre, o
ascorbil. Ou seja, a vitamina C pode se
deteriorar devido à ação dos radicais
livres. E aí que entram os flavonoides
para ajudar, para proteger a vitamina C.
Então, qualquer alimento que contém
vitamina C também contém flavonoides,
por exemplo, limões, laranjas, acerola,
repolho, mirtilos e várias outras frutas
e vegetais. Portanto, consumir alimentos
ricos em vitamina C e flavonoides não
apenas garante a absorção adequada da
vitamina, mas também protege a própria
vitamina C da deterioração. Isso quer
dizer que os suplementos não funcionam?
Não exatamente. Existem problemas que
podem dificultar a manutenção de níveis
adequados de vitamina C no corpo,
levando a necessidade de experimentação.
Mas antes de falar desses problemas,
vamos falar sobre a quantidade de
vitamina C que você precisa. Se formos
olhar de acordo com os órgãos oficiais,
a dose diária recomendada é de 75 a 90
mg para um adulto. Isso é considerado
suficiente por dia pra maioria das
pessoas. Eu digo para vocês
sinceramente, quando ouço a palavra
suficiente ou necessário, penso que isso
é o mínimo para você sobreviver, para
manter o seu organismo funcionando no
que diz respeito ao que essa vitamina
faz basicamente no seu corpo, o básico
do básico. Mas eu não quero apenas
manter o mínimo para sobreviver, eu
quero prosperar, eu quero otimizar.
Então, quanto de vitamina C é necessário
por dia para estar com uma saúde mais
otimizada? Para prosperarmos, para
otimizarmos nossa saúde, precisamos de
cerca de 400 mg de vitamina C por dia, o
que parece ser uma quantidade muito boa
para manter o corpo saudável e forte pra
maioria das pessoas que não estão com
deficiência. Agora, falando de forma
resumida sobre os benefícios da vitamina
C, ela fortalece o sistema de defesa, o
sistema imune, melhora a saúde
cardiovascular, saúde arterial, protege
a pele também contra danos. Você já deve
ter ouvido que a vitamina C é importante
paraa formação de colágeno, essa
proteína estrutural tão importante. Além
disso, ela promove a cicatrização de
feridas, combate radicais livres que
causam doenças e pode prevenir certos
tipos de câncer. Também fortalece unhas
e cabelos, protege o estômago e ajuda na
melhor absorção de ferro dos alimentos.
Mais do que isso, estudos mostraram que
pessoas que tomaram 1 g de vitamina C
por dia tiveram menos probabilidade de
adoecer, faltaram menos ao trabalho por
doenças como gripses e tiveram menos
resfriados. Isso demonstra que a
vitamina C realmente fortalece o sistema
de defesa, o sistema imune. A
suplementação de vitamina C tem outras
utilidades importantes, especialmente
altas doses, que devem ser administradas
somente com acompanhamento médico. Ela é
utilizada, por exemplo, na terapia do
câncer para ajudar no tratamento e
também há estudos que indicam que altas
doses de vitamina C poderiam evitar a
formação de placa nas artérias. No
passado, havia uma doença conhecida como
escorbuto, causada por uma deficiência
grave de vitamina C. Embora hoje em dia
um escorbuto clássico seja considerado
erradicado, ainda existe uma forma mais
leve chamada de escorbuto subclínico,
que é caracterizada por uma deficiência
significativa de vitamina C. E quais são
então os sinais dessa deficiência de
vitamina C que você pode observar? Uma
língua mais avermelhada e brilhante com
manchas vermelhas nas laterais.
Isso se deve a microhemorragias.
Também pode acontecer sangramentos nas
gingivas, imunidade baixa levando a
frequentes resfriados e gripes,
articulações doloridas sem causa
aparente, cicatrização mais lenta de
feridas, hematomas, né, ou aqueles roxos
no corpo que surgem sem motivo aparente,
pele flasta envelhecida, cabelos e unhas
mais frágeis. Então, esses são os
principais sintomas e sinais para
identificar uma falta de vitamina C.
Para confirmar a deficiência, quando os
sintomas não são tão claros assim,
existem alguns exames, embora não sejam
totalmente conclusivos ou confiáveis. O
exame de sangue para medir a vitamina C
pode ajudar, mas não é totalmente
confiável, porque a vitamina C está
principalmente concentrada dentro dos
leucostos, das células brancas de defesa
ou glóbulos brancos. Como esses
leucostos utilizam muita vitamina C para
combater infecções, medir a vitamina C
no sangue pode não refletir a quantidade
real no corpo. Há também um método de
teste que mede a excreção de vitamina C
na urina. O paciente toma vitamina C e
depois a urina é coletada. O excesso de
vitamina C na urina indica que o corpo
não precisou daquela vitamina. Aí isso
pode sugerir níveis adequados. Por outro
lado, pouca vitamina C na urina indica
que o corpo utilizou toda a quantidade
ingerida e disponível e isso sugere uma
deficiência. No final das contas, a
maneira mais simples e confiável de
saber se você precisa de mais vitamina C
e qual é a dose necessária é avaliar não
só os exames de sangue urina, mas também
a sua dieta, saúde gastrointestinal,
presença de problemas como falta de
ácido no estômago e níveis de estresse.
O médico vai considerar todos esses
fatores para fazer uma avaliação
completa, identificar se você precisa
suplementar ou não. E por que
suplementar a vitamina C? Quem deve
fazer isso, pessoal? Eu acho que é muito
importante suplementar a vitamina C para
pessoas que ficam constantemente
resfriadas ou gripadas e para fumantes
idosos também. A vitamina C é essencial
para o sistema de defesa, o sistema
imune. Por quê? Os nossos linfócitos, um
tipo de glóbulo branco, quando estão
combatendo infecções, podem danificar
tanto o corpo quanto a si próprios
devido aos radicais livres que eles
produzem para matar os bichos. Então,
esses radicais livres são como fogo,
causando danos. Para se proteger, os
glóbulos brancos utilizam a vitamina C
das nossas reservas. Então, durante uma
infecção, o nosso corpo consome muita
vitamina C para neutralizar as radicais
livres, o que pode levar a uma
deficiência dessa vitamina. Portanto, a
suplementação de vitamina C é importante
para pessoas que ficam frequentemente
doentes. Outra questão importante sobre
a suplementação de vitamina C é a função
do nosso estômago. A absorção da
vitamina C depende muito do pH do
estômago. Então, pacientes que sofrem de
problemas como hipocloridria, que a
falta de ácido ou pouco ácido no
estômago, ou mesmo ausência desse ácido,
que é a cloridria, podem ter níveis
baixos de vitamina C, mesmo consumindo
alimentos ricos nesse elemento ou até
suplementando. Quando há falta de ácido
clorídrico no estômago, isso é
problemático porque a vitamina C acaba
sendo inutilizada, o que impede a sua
absorção eficaz. Então, além disso, para
pessoas com deficiência de ferro ou
anemia, a suplementação de vitamina C
pode ser fundamental, já que a vitamina
C trabalha em conjunto com ferro para
neutralizar a sua oxidação, ajudando a
tornar esse ferro mais disponível para
ser utilizado pelo organismo. Outro caso
em que a suplementação de vitamina C
pode ser útil é em situações de estresse
crônico e contínuo, uma situação que
consome muita vitamina C. Então, vamos
falar agora das doses e tipos de
suplementação da vitamina C. Para
suplementar a vitamina C de forma
eficaz, é importante tomá-la e
diariamente, mesmo antes de sentir os
sintomas da gripe. Se você começar a
tomar vitamina C apenas quando já está
gripado, o efeito vai ser bem menor. Por
isso, durante uma gripe, a dose de
vitamina C deve ser maior enquanto você
estiver com sintomas ou infecção. Se
você tem uma deficiência comprovada de
vitamina C ou está buscando níveis
terapêuticos, é essencial seguir a
orientação do seu médico ou médica. Para
quem não tem deficiência e deseja apenas
manter a saúde geral e percebe que não
consome o suficiente de alimentos ricos
em vitamina C, o ideal é suplementar de
forma contínua, mas com doses menores e,
se possível, mais de uma vez ao dia.
Isso ajuda a manter os níveis de
vitamina C estáveis, mais equilibrados
no organismo. Por exemplo, doses diária
de 500 mg a 1 g adequadas e suficientes.
Você pode tomar 500 mg de manhã, 500 mg
no final da tarde ou dividir esse 250 mg
de manhã, 250 mg à tarde. Então, é
importante manter a suplementação
constante nesses casos, especialmente
durante os meses ou períodos em que as
infecções são mais comuns. Se você já
está gripado, viajando ou um evento com
muitas pessoas, pode aumentar a dose
para 2 g por dia, divididos em quatro
tomadas de 500 mg. Após esse período de
risco, volte pra dose diária de 500 a 1
g ao dia. Se você estiver utilizando uma
fa de vitamina C melhor, absorção, mais
absorvível, como a vitamina C
lipossomal, 500 mg por dia pode ser
suficiente para uma pessoa saudável. A
vitamina C lipossomal é encapsulada em
lipossomas, pequenas partículas de
gordura que protege a vitamina C durante
a absorção, aumentando a sua eficácia ao
entregá-la diretamente aos tecidos do
corpo. Evite a vitamina C fvescente de
farmácia, que geralmente tem corantes,
conservantes e açúcar, além de ter uma
absorção menor. No entanto, se for a
única opção que você encontrar, a única
disponível, pode ser utilizado sim, mas
sem abusar efeitos colaterais. E nesse
caso do uso da vitamina C de farmácia,
prefira a vitamina C revestida com
liberação prolongada, que é projetada
para permitir que a vitamina C seja
liberada de forma gradual no seu trato
digestório. Esse revestimento pode
ajudar a evitar a irritação do estômago
em algumas pessoas que podem
experimentar desconforto, gastintestinal
ao tomar vitamina C em sua forma ácida
padrão. E existe risco de experimentar
vitamina C? Sim, tem risco. Existe risco
de experimentação. Apesar de ser
bastante segura, doses acima de 3 g por
dia podem causar alguns efeitos
colaterais, nada graves, mas que podem
incomodar, como dores no estômago e
diarreia em algumas pessoas. Há também o
risco de formação de cálculos renais,
cálculo ou pedra nos ins, especialmente
em homens, porque a vitamina C pode se
converter em oxalato no corpo,
contribuindo para a formação de pedra
nos ins. Portanto, quem tem tendência a
formar cálculos deve evitar a
suplementação de vitamina C, a menos que
indicada por um médico, mas isso é
evitado também se você tomar bastante
água, estiver muito bem hidratado. A
vitamina C também aumenta a absorção de
cálcio e ferro, o que pode ser benéfico
para muitos, mas para quem tem excesso
de cálcio ou ferritina alta, a
suplementação deve ser monitorizada por
um médico. Além disso, a vitamina C
aumenta a absorção de alumínio, então é
recomendável evitar cozinhar em panelas
de alumínio ou consumir alimentos ou
suplementos com alumínio ao suplementar
a vitamina C. Existem medicamentos que
podem interagir com a vitamina C, por
isso é sempre importante consultar um
médico antes de usar suplementos de
vitamina C, especialmente em doses
altas. Compartilhe os vídeos, faça o
bem. A vida de alguém pode mudar também
no canal do Dor
se envolva. Muito obrigado pela sua
atenção, um grande abraço, um beijo no
seu coração. Você é fera.